oh it was very bad the new york times
says that trump's speech was dark and
divisive
at mount rushmore leaning into culture
wars and barely mentioning the pandemic
can you believe that in a speech that
had nothing to do with the pandemic it
meant rushmore right before the fourth
of july he didn't mention the pandemic
that we're trying to push he didn't
mention our narrative he didn't play
into it
cnn called it dark and divisive and and
they
obviously nothing in the text of the
speech was dark or divisive we just
talked about how great our history was
how great those men were how great we
are and how great we can be in the
future because the best is yet to come
so they had to look at the site they
said the very fact
that they're at mount rushmore is
evidence of how dark and evil and racist
and bigoted and unjust
this man is here's cnn kicking off the
independence day weekend president trump
will be
at mount rushmore where he'll be
standing in front of a monument
of two slave owners and on land wrestled
away from
native americans told that uh be
focusing on the effort to quote
tear down our country's history that's
really awful and dark and awful isn't it
i guess cnn just hates mount rushmore
maybe there's something wrong with mount
rushmore
maybe we've just been so wrong about
this all the time oh no
it's pure hypocrisy because four years
ago
when bernie sanders noted left winger
showed up to mount rushmore
cnn could not have been happier
this is our country in its very best
what an incredible achievement
visiting mount rushmore today bernie
sanders taking in the majesty of the
moment
this monument to four great american
presidents
just the accomplishment and the beauty
here it really does make one
very proud to be an american this is
america at its best it makes you proud
to be an american
it's so beautiful even cnn admits four
great american presidents
you know it's fake when it's in the news
that was a line from kanye west's recent
song
kanye west possibly our future president
which we'll get to in a moment
this is what fake news is they don't
care about mount rushmore
they don't care about george washington
or thomas jefferson they
just care about attacking trump and
donald trump is the representative
for you they want to attack you who they
think are deplorable and irredeemable
and bitter clingers
and all manner of evil
the the instrument through which they
will attack you
doesn't matter if bernie sanders if joe
biden
i guess now as the nominee had given a
speech at mount rushmore
all we would have heard for the last two
weeks is how great mount rushmore is
if joe biden had given a speech on how
wonderful george washington is
we'd have we'd have heard hour to our 24
7 media coverage
of how george washington was a great man
and how he would have hated donald trump
there's no solid logic here it's just
democrat good republican bad
biden good trump bad left good
right bad that's all it is and and there
are some squishy people
on the right who who want to say uh
maybe they've got a point you know maybe
maybe we shouldn't have mount mount
rushmore maybe we shouldn't
ah you know jefferson didn't it's it's
not about that guy
you're just you're trying to appease
people and come to an accommodation
with people who have no desire to
reconcile with you on the left
they just want to club you and attack
you
and the the sooner you you can pull up
an example from the media
for all virtually all of these stories
how many do you have to watch before you
realize
they don't want to be friends with you
okay they don't they don't like you very
much
they don't like this country
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses
spend less time billing and more time
making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description